you know something that I something that
I talk about a lot
is the fake wives and I want to start
talking about archetypes of fake wives
because a lot of times women come in and
say I am the authority on marriage I
have been married 10
I mean I'm not gonna say names but I've
been married 10 20 30 40 years now the
40-year marriages tend to be a bit more
legit but let's look at the 10 20 25
year marriages okay let's look at those
um and what I what I call these
are really the wives in sheep's clothing
these women don't believe in being a
wife they're not submissive like a wife
is supposed to be and they they've
typically lived a very feminist
lifestyle but claim trap even though
it's very clear to the outside world
that they are not so I have a couple
archetypes that I'm kind of working on
and if you guys have any um if you have
any additions please put them in the
comments but I thought of the
controlling wife
so this is a woman that's married and
feels like her husband needs to ask her
permission and her guidance on
everything you see this a lot in the
Christian church
um uh what I what I call the controlling
wife a lot of times these women will
weaponize the Bible against their
husband to get them to do exactly what
they want next I call the nagging wife
now the nagging wife is the wife and and
sometimes women have archetypes of more
than one the nagging wife is is the
woman whose husband can never do
anything right
she will Nag on him for a lifetime it
doesn't matter if he's a world-renowned
superstar if he's a top one percent guy
nothing he does is ever good enough and
you can identify this wife
um by seeing
a woman that disrespects her guy in
public kind of belittles him I was
trying to think of how I could describe
the Jada Pinkett Smith wives now these
wives
um typically have hyphenated last names
they don't want to completely submit to
the authority of the man that they're
with and I I almost I was thinking the
leftover wives where there really there
was a different guy they wanted to be
this and they feel like they settled for
their husband now I'm open to
suggestions maybe next show um you guys
put it in the comments we'll together
come up with a name
um but these wives typically
kind of get into some weird [__] later
they're very attention addicted they
tend to be failed actresses
um I I kind of I see kind of Steph
Curry's wife is the same sort of
archetype and you know they get older
and they just start engaging in some
weird [__]
um you know with with Jade I was like
the open relationship but you start to
see these women where maybe when they
were younger they had a higher sexual
market value than their husbands and
when the attention is starting to go
they just start to go nuts they start to
go crazy insane what the The Telltale
sign of these wives is their husbands
typically put them on a pedestal so I I
see Steve Harvey's wife Marjorie kind of
the same way
um their wives are so amazing and
awesome they're so lucky to be with
their wives when guys that's out of
order as a woman you are lucky to be
with your husband that is the that is
the natural order of things it doesn't
work the other way around so typically
these wives have an enabling husband who
lets them think they're more important
than special than they are
um they typically have an ex-boyfriend
that they liked better than their
husband or an ex-husband you know
typically he might have been a drug
dealer or some sort of bad boy okay and
typically
um they do not give their husbands the
respect and Authority that they deserve
in their own households
um
and they they constantly disrespect
their husbands in public
I'm open to suggestions on names but so
Jada Pickett is married to Will Smith
now Will Smith is a guy that most women
would deem
pretty awesome okay pretty pretty you'd
be pretty lucky to be with a guy like
well
he's worth
millions of dollars
he is attractive he is tall he is Rich
and um he has status he's one of the
most loved actors of all time you know
Men start to ask the question if a guy
like will can't keep his wife happy what
chance do I have
so Jada dated Tupac Back in the day they
had you know they called it I don't know
just like a Love or whatever and Tupac I
mean I I don't guys I'm not a die-hard
Tupac fan I know people are very very
like defensive of him
but it
I mean his lyrics were of his songs were
about some crazy stuff and you know he's
a rapper so he's more of a bad boy
archetype than will will say that where
will is kind of more of the family man
and um
Jada throughout their you know 20-year
marriage I really think speaks higher of
Tupac than her own husband can you
imagine
being worth that much money having that
being that good looking having that much
status and allowing your wife to talk
higher of an ex-boyfriend than of you so
Jada Smith shares a video of her and
Tupac
lip syncing to Will Smith's parents
don't just don't understand
[Music]
yeah you know so your wife imagine
imagine your wife is sharing a video of
her like flirting with another dude you
know an ex-boyfriend is that is that
appropriate and I see guys I've heard
these horror stories
why do so many daughters know who their
mother's ex-boyfriends were
why are you telling your kid about him
I've even heard horror stories of men
finding out their daughter or son was
named after a woman's ex-boyfriend
can you imagine
oh my
and you wonder why marriage is such a
dangerous Institution for men I mean
what would what would what would a
divorce for Will Smith look like right
now
and even if he's single what type of
women are going to go after him
typically I would say more predatory
women I don't even know if a rich guy
like finding love is easier I I don't
even know if it is because really
I mean the the number of predatory
chicks that go after these guys
it's tough it's tough sex is definitely
easier for them okay but I was curious
on like Will's view on this so I found a
clip of Will Smith talking about he's
actually jealous of the love Jada had
for Tupac let's pull it up you ever
jealous of the love Jada had for too
long oh yeah
that was in the early days yeah that was
in the early days and it was like that
was a big regret for me too because I
could never I could never open up to
interact with with pop you know and
because we had a little bit of a thing
right because you know you know they
grew up together and you know they loved
each other but they never had that you
know they never had a sexual
relationship but they had come into that
age where now that was a possibility and
then Jada was with me you know so you
know Park had a little thing on that
um but she just loved him like he was
the image of perfection but she was with
the Fresh Prince you know so that was a
huge regret of mine I just didn't I
couldn't I couldn't handle it you know I
was just I was the soft rapper from
Philly and he was Pock and how and how
sad is that this guy has accomplished
all he's accomplished and he still can't
live up to the ghosts of her past you
know he he's talking about how he's a
soft rapper from Philly a man how much
is he worth like 200 million dollars
300 like imagine imagine
um and you know it's you can almost see
the conditioning where he kind of knows
it's not right where you know he's like
I couldn't open up to him I couldn't
talk to him because men have like an
innate gut feeling about stuff women we
just our emotions take us God knows
wherever but not having innate like I
don't know Spidey senses about things
but women kind of manipulate them and
try to get them to not listen to their
gut and that is the that is the biggest
that is the you cannot do that as a guy
because looking now he's conditioned
into thinking that he should have opened
up to Tupac more that this behavior is
okay people think I'm being dramatic
when I say marriage can be a prison and
a death sentence for men but a lot of
times men not having Authority in their
own households is a prison for them
and I found this clip of Will Smith
being filmed without his consent at home
um and it really demonstrates that
perfectly let me show you
you know Sarah Pharrell is coming to the
table she's gonna be at the red table
would you say she has been instrumental
in you and I redefining our relationship
I would say Don't just start filming me
without asking me oh my goodness
stay or come help us again please I'm
still dealing with foolishness don't no
no she yeah cause she don't just would
you say that she helped us heal the
hurts that we caused between one another
my social media presence is my bread and
butter okay so you can't just use me for
social media and not you know don't just
start rolling I'm standing in my house
don't just start rolling
yeah so so this guy is in his own home
and is what what would you do if you're
an obedient wife and you you're filming
your husband and he says to put it away
do you roll your eyes and say oh my
goodness or do you say okay
and there's a whole generation of women
that have the Rings they look like a
duck quack like a duck but they're not a
duck and that's what I would describe
the wives of today they look like wives
they might dress like wives but they're
not wives because it's a mentality more
than anything you know in women they'll
sell these femininity courses right
um which make their looks better
um how to dress better whatever but but
they don't have the most important thing
and life is long
um you know let's say we all live to be
80. 50 to 80. who's really got who's
really that good looking I mean men or
women right I mean the men hold out in
their 50s but like come on guys
um the most important thing is obedience
and what they miss about femininity
actually real true femininity is serving
the men in your life okay I don't don't
shoot the messenger and I have a lot of
empathy for um Jada's daughter uh Willow
and Willows just kind of I mean she's
like doing the cross-dressing thing uh
she was already in a throuple like this
woman was in a throuple relationship at
16. and I'll tell you before all of the
stuff with Will and Jada came out I knew
something was wrong in that household
because the kids were too messed up
something is off when the kids are this
woke and liberal maybe we could call her
the woke wife maybe that's actually a
good a good name for that archetype the
woke wife
um
but I I knew I knew something was off
like nobody could tell me different